إذا لم يحمي Facebook الأطفال ، فنحن على
الأقل بحاجة إلى مساعدة الوالدين على
حماية الأطفال ، لذا فإن فكرة أنك
تعرف أن 20 من مستخدميك قد يواجهون
مشكلات خطيرة في الصحة العقلية وهذه
ليست مشكلة صادمة لـ
[الموسيقى]
الخاصة بـ facebook  تقول الأبحاث أن
instagram هو في الواقع أسوأ بشكل واضح
من قول tick tock أو snapchat أو reddit
um لأن instagram ticktalk يدور حول
القيام بأشياء ممتعة مع أصدقائك ، فإن
snapchat تدور حول الوجوه والواقع المعزز.
في الوقت الحالي ، لا أحد يستطيع إجبار
Facebook على الكشف عن البيانات ،
وقد قام Facebook بمنعنا أو حتى الأسوأ من ذلك
أنهم قدموا بيانات غير دقيقة للباحثين
حيث أظهرت الفضيحة مؤخرًا أن فريقي
عمل بشكل مباشر على
تتبع المشاركة الصينية على
المنصة التي تقوم بالمسح ، ويقول
السكان الأضعف في الأماكن حول  في العالم
رأينا أيضًا
إقناعًا نشطًا بالقول إن
الحكومة الإيرانية تقوم بالتجسس على جهات حكومية أخرى
[موسيقى]
لذا
أنت